We will now look at three App Engine success
stories that are representative, because they use the strengths
of App Engine. The first one is a real-time
earthquake monitoring system in japan. So in this picture, lots
of data is collected by NIED, which is an
institute in Japan. They look at the data and then
send image files to App Engine, every second. Clients
can then view these images files to see the activity.
Well, as you can imagine, when there is no earthquake
activity, there are not many clients that are interested in
watching this system. But on the other hand, when there
is earthquake activity, the system needs to serve a lot of
data to many clients. And this is, of course, a
great application for App Engine. Which can scale the number
of instances up and down, depending on the activity and
the number of clients accessing the system. Another great success story
of App Engine is Song Pop, an app you
may have used, which is a game where you guess
the song or an artist. Well, Song Pop grew
from zero to 10,000 queries per second in six months.
And as of early 2013, it had more than
60 million users. Song Pop uses app engine, again, because
of its ability to rapidly scale up and down based
on the user load. And one that you've certainly heard
about is Rovio, the creator of Angry Birds. When Rovio developed a web
based version of Angry Birds, they used
App Engine because of its automatic scaling.
But also for many of the other functions it provides. And these things
are exactly what you will learn when you take this course. So stay tuned.